[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans coming at you
from quarantine that's right we are live
and direct here
from the living room for your season 11
fan q a questions we reached out to you
guys on twitter
we reached out to you guys on facebook
we reached out to you guys on youtube
and overwhelming the big question that
we got from fans covid19
how does this global pandemic affect hot
ones
the long and short of it is uh we don't
really know
uh we're just like you guys watching the
news keeping up to date on all the
updates and
reacting accordingly so the plan in the
short term is to kick things back
a few weeks a month maybe longer i'm not
sure and then in the meantime
find some fun ways to connect with you
guys on a more regular basis
keep the hot ones team working cause
that's all we know how to do it doesn't
slow down
it doesn't stop and neither does the
season 11
fan q a you guys had some great
questions this year
let's dive right into them and first up
we have
guy under the pillow how come you never
brought up to jt
that he's your doppelganger well the
first rule of doppelganger recognition
is you can't tell your doppelganger hey
you're my doppelganger you have to wait
for the other person to bring it up
so i'm not just gonna sit there and say
to jt like hey jt
a lot of people on the internet say that
we look alike and i take it as a huge
compliment
what do you think of that you can't say
that to jt look at me
he's gonna think of that as an insult
you have to wait for him
to bring it up that said first we
feasted a poll recently
and they had all the people that the
internet says that i kind of look like
overwhelming favorite neil patrick
harris and that is something
that has been going on since long before
i was on youtube
all right up next from sabona argo
how many people are in your research
team all right so uh here's how it works
uh me chris schoenberger and my little
brother gavin we divide up the research
take our notes compile them we have our
dossier
we use that as the source and then uh me
and chris write the run of show
write the interview questions that's how
it was in the beginning and that's how
it'll be till the end
all right up next
[Music]
all right real quick i'm going to
interrupt the mail bag to do controversy
corner because it's my favorite part of
every hot ones q
a this year though i feel like we were
pretty clean but uh let's address a
couple things
lots of people reaching out there's uh
some episodes that are off youtube what
happened to the chrissy teigen episode
for crying out loud even chrissy teigen
wants to know
the way it works is after hot wins the
game show there's a hot ones episode so
we pulled the episodes off youtube
once that's all done those episodes that
were down back on youtube
uh that's how it goes not my decision
don't be mad at me but i also don't
think it's the world's biggest deal
finally
a big controversy did you have kovid19
we saw you
in the update special you had a cut on
your chin you fainted twice in the
middle of the night
what the hell is going on what are you
keeping from us sean
who knows i couldn't get a test when i
reached out i was like to my physician
i'm like
i think things are wrong i fainted twice
last night i've never fainted before in
my life look at this damn cut on my chin
and they were like yeah oh uh rest
you don't have the severe breathing
symptoms that we associate with somebody
who needs a test
so i didn't get a test but to answer
your question i don't i don't know maybe
i did
you know what i was sick a couple weeks
before i don't know
you read all this new stuff when did
when was it in the country where more
people were infected
i can't keep up with the headlines and
thus concludes controversy corner
all right back to the mailbag
from bryceop29 what's your favorite kind
of cheese
mine manchego from blood moon priestess
on ig
where do you think the future of
television is headed because of mediums
like youtube and tiktok
is making it to tv still considered an
accomplishment or is youtube created an
environment where it might actually be a
step down uh first off i do think
there's like a weird
tribalism between tv and youtube that i
don't fully understand
uh the thing i think about is uh when we
had pete holmes on hot ones and he was
talking about if you have an idea
maybe it's better as a drawing or
cartoon maybe it's better as a novel
and that's the way these different
platforms work it's not a
one-size-fits-all thing
certain platforms have limitations like
uh the game show for example we could
never do that on youtube to do a big
game show you have to do that on tv if
we try to do that on youtube and
bankrupt the channel in the first week
even look at like right now there's a
there's a whole situation where like
it doesn't matter if you're jimmy fallon
host of the tonight show or whatever
you're doing this look
i'm in my [ __ ] living room right now
there's been a total reset button on
entertainment
where everybody's stripped of their
productions and now they're just
everyone's a vlogger
who knows it just seems to be changing
so much it's a very complicated question
um maybe the next entire q a is about
this because i'm a i'm a
i am a media landscape
junkie i'm obsessed with it i love
talking about it all right but we don't
have time for me to keep rambling on
there's more questions to go so moving
on
riddle go bra on ig asks what's your
go-to spot for good food in atlanta
atlanta is an awesome city we spent a
lot of time there shooting the game show
i was there for a couple weeks
did a lot of eating i went to the spot
echo a couple times which is excellent
but the most memorable dining experience
that i had in atlanta was at this place
called gun show
and what they do there is you you feel
like you're a
judge on top chef they have like 10
chefs in the kitchen
and maybe they make up like two or three
dishes a night
and then they come to your table and try
to sell you the dish
if you're eating with a big group like
we're eating you try a little bit of
everything
and then the fun thing about that is
there's stuff that maybe you'd look at
the menu and you'd be like
that's up my alley i'm gonna order that
and then when you actually try
everything you're like oh that was only
okay but that's the dish i would have
ordered
and then you know what happens the
dishes that you maybe would have ignored
are your favorites and then you start to
think well what do i even know about
anything
and i learned that at the gun show from
that one wookie
what two questions do you most dislike
being asked well i'm sort of
desensitized to the whole like
when are you gonna have with this guy on
the ship when are you going to have
keanu regional show when are you going
to have uh well smith on the show when
are you going to have obama on the show
that stuff like i'm just desensitized to
it so when people are like what are you
going to do this when are you going to
do that when are you going to do this
um i'm just like you know
and then the other one that's like that
is when people like well how do you do
it how do you do how do you eat those
weight i don't know how you do it
which is i get it being asked i
understand it but i have been asked that
a million times and now i'm just bored
with it to the point that it's like
exhausting to answer
like i don't know i just do it like i
used to work in a cubicle that was a
whole lot more painful
than this abe the gremlin asked us on
twitter
what's your favorite song with the word
hot in it i'm gonna have to go with uh
snoop dogg and pharrell
drop it like it's hot and then honorable
mention bobby schmerda
okay moving on top comment on instagram
jesus treo host of tacos cone toto asks
do you own socks hey jesus what's it
look like
i got socks baby i got socks i got lots
of socks
but you know what hey listen i'm just
chilling in my apartment
if i don't want to wear socks i won't
wear socks you guys are lucky i wore
pants i almost didn't wear pants to this
from pooh rogan top 80s cartoons and why
i'm a 90s kid so the 80s stuff it's like
a little bit before me like what is that
like thundercats and
gi joe american hero and like
inspector gadget i never watched any of
that that's all before my time
but i will give you my mount rushmore
of cartoons number one south park
i think that there were four seasons of
the simpsons that are untouchable
beavis and butthead also on there in
that last spot
a little bit of a cult show and that's
the critic
those are my four favorite animated
shows of all time
honorable mentions go to the tick
futurama that was my brother's favorite
show and then
a third another little curveball but it
was the funniest show
dr katz justin valley asks
being a crystal lake native what would
be your top three
hometown hot spots for food we have
tommy's two dog special portillos
and then here's a real deep dive
from the 815. do you guys remember that
that strip mall
where there was a leap in lizards there
was a dollar video
there was a prime time sports
collectibles and then on the end
you know kind of in that corner shout
out another crystal lake spot real quick
nick's pizza pub it's near there
kind of cradled in there in that strip
mall
that chinese spot it has long since gone
out of business but growing up
best egg foo young best chicken fried
rice
another side rant uh i used to play
little league behind there
the major one fields they were back
there uh and you remember how kids in
little league like if they were playing
on like
burger king they'd say they get free
burger king or mcdonald's or like there
were kids that worked on dollar video
it's like oh yeah like they're acting
like
they had perks like they got free
rentals and stuff i've gotten older
and i realized that those were all lies
i was always so bummed out that like
my team would be like a dentist's office
or something i was like look at these
kids we're playing they
they all get they'll get free rentals
from dollar video but that was all a lie
what was that all about shout out uh
crystalline national little league
legends
luke treasurer nick chrisman and petice
all right moving on from melpers17
sean do you pick your own outfits or is
there a hot one
stylist that assists you all me baby
shopping is not my favorite thing in the
world i have a little bit of interest in
it
i'm a little bit of a hobbyist kind of
like know what's going on but not really
ask some people call what's this i'm a
little bit interested
not so much that it consumes me or that
i care all that much
uh but uniform shopper i know what i
like i know what i like but i'm a simple
man
shout out throwing fits shout out chuck
shout out larry
all right moving on from vamp ever
thought of making a podcast
all right here's my thing with podcasts
i i agree that like now is like a golden
era
in podcasts it's a gold rush you know
the the radio it's not what they used to
be so now you just have like
where people used to crank the am dial
and get talk radio or whatever now it's
just
podcast podcast podcasts
they look like such a pain in the ass
every friend of mine that has a podcast
they're just constantly scrambling
trying to get guests uh there's a whole
circuit you do my podcast i'll do your
podcast blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and i'm like where
does it end that's a lot of work and i
know how hard it is
to lock in guests because it is a
massive undertaking here on hot ones
i would not want to take this project
which already taxes us
and then add another get guest podcast
except now the show's got to be two and
a half hours long or something like that
that seems to me insane i can't do it if
i were to make a podcast this is what i
would do
is doing a white sox podcast with my
brother where we just
talk about the white socks but it's also
me and my brother
kind of uh connecting on this thing that
we used to love as kids
so maybe the shawn and gavin white sox
podcast if we ever get sports again
from stannie dewyer since reaching an
audience of millions
do you now feel pressure to pick the
most known celebrities over perhaps
the most interesting or niche characters
on the internet alright well it seems
like we've gone from who gate
to the guests are too famous now so i
see what's going on here
uh but to answer your question sure we
could have a blueprint before the season
and be like oh we want like
this mix of actors and actresses a few
musicians
maybe an athlete who just won a
championship a white whale guess that
the uh
that the audience has been clamoring for
since the beginning
and then if things get too clean around
here we need a comedian
to drop bombs come in with some edge and
do one of those anarchy episodes that we
love to make
that's great you can have that blueprint
but that's not
how it works at all but we've been
fortunate enough
now to be in a position where we have a
lot of incoming too so that's how it
works
you have outgoing stuff the trail gets
warm it gets hot
bam locking a date put it on the
schedule incoming oh my gosh this person
just
hit us up they're going to be here there
whatever they want to do hot ones all
right
put it on the schedule and then you
start putting it on the schedule and
then once that ship gets going the
production ship
it's like a cruise ship it's hard to
turn but the hot one ship
it has to be able to turn on a dime and
just be this big beast thing that moves
but
we have very little uh wiggle room so
yeah
you can have that blueprint but you
cannot
build it out like that it'll never work
out for you that way
you just have to be opportunistic make
the best of whatever's handed to you and
philosophically
here's the thing that we drive in to
everybody who works on the show
it does not matter who's in the seat you
just have to do
the best possible interview and not sulk
and be like oh i wish it was
well smith or whatever you cannot think
that way
you cannot go about things that way the
thing is
whoever's in the seat no matter who it
is best interview possible
and i think that's why the show's lasted
as long as it's lasted
well there you have it another hot ones
fan q a is in the books
if you sent us a question thank you very
much
if you've watched us this season or if
you've watched us in any season
if we've gotten a minute of your time i
just want to say thank you
season one all the way to season 11. who
would have thought
not me uh we covered a lot but again uh
stick with us because we're gonna stay
connected to you
uh we'll do a new thing shawn tells a
story i'll get on here i'll tell you
i'll take you down and walk down memory
lane
i'll talk about the shark tank i don't
know i'll figure it out but if you want
to stay connected
i'm going to try to stay connected with
you again when it comes to hot ones
updates
you guys will be the first to know in
the meantime
take care of yourselves stay home and
we'll see you
very soon
it doesn't have the same ring it doesn't
have the same ring when you're just
doing it yourself
thank you thank you
what is up spice lords this is camera
guy bill here
welcome to bill's wing tutorial
there's one thing this buffalo boy knows
how to do it's eat a wing
first you're gonna wet your wing with
some sauce here pour a little drizzle
there
and then i like to do i uh
i pull it apart and then you get two
wings for the price of one you just
[Music]
move it up
for more tutorials on how to eat chicken
wings smash that subscribe and like
button
this is camera guy bill here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill